spooks people out elliptical camping
with you one day Oh bro why dude you and
I campus you and me camping where were
you gonna camp right outside of here I
can't see you going very far no no no
we're gonna call wrong or you just
saying things you see I really do think
that you and I could go camping I love
this amp and sometime you and I well
he's from Georgia so he doesn't come he
doesn't come just you and I we could get
some things done
yeah Michael I need to comes to make
sure that you eat and that I who's gonna
do anything you and I are gonna born I
would starve to death dude in a [ __ ]
grocery store okay we could are you on
tour Z at all huh are you outdoorsy at
all yeah I like to be outdoors man oh
man I'm a mommy you know girls like I'll
go out there and wait for an uber you
don't wait inside all right
so yeah but you seem like you from the
outdoors oh I mean I know some things I
spent a lot of time outdoors growing up
you know I think here's what we think my
California yeah kind of immune to some
of that in a weird way it's our Los
Angeles I think the rest of America you
you're more in the elements more yeah
but when I was in Honduras I was in
Honduras for a month Honduras exactly
yeah and Carlos Mencia took me there oh
wow and I was complaining the whole boat
ride over there mm-hmm
we landed and you have to take a boat
there yeah because you we landed on the
major airport then we took another
little plane to another like a field
mm-hmm and then we had to take a four
hour like boat ride to his village
mm-hmm and during the boat ride I was
complaining the whole time Wow yes girl
younger that's how I sound that's all
screaming that [ __ ] is that a cow the
dead cow in the river say to you idiot
that's not a [ __ ] rott
that's a day it is daddy yeah and when I
got there I was complaining for three
days mmm let me see that there's no
toilet you can flush nothing right yeah
[ __ ] in a frisbee two weeks later I was
walking around naked with a spear I
think
acclimated the kids will follow me
around the village kid right we were
like on logs like paneling see ourselves
on logs and [ __ ] like I became a
primitive man I can adapt really see
that I could see em hmm I don't know I
don't really can't I really can't see
you adapt and actually but I did yeah
but that was then no aunt nope
what do you mean van dude you said it
was back then yeah but like 20 years ago
yeah and you're so different now I know
but I think that I have the ability to
do it do you remember what it feels like
to even be hungry at all yeah oh yeah
hungry the other day man I mean I was
hungry in my hotel room and in Portland
what'd you do I sort of walk to the Red
Robin and what you fainted there's a Red
Robin by the house and I try to map
question it was you know how you when
you're walking in mop mapquesting you
don't know what yeah you'll go straight
to heaven if you walk in yeah and I was
going and I was and then all of a sudden
I I didn't want nine blocks I was going
the opposite direction oh right so I
didn't know what to do and I was so
hungry I'd woken up at 4:00 p.m. there's
the hook there's no food at the hotel
he's sort of an old dad in that way like
he doesn't have the uber app or the post
mates app on his phone it's all online
I don't know how to lose it and he still
prints out directions from MapQuest I do
like he doesn't know how to use apps at
all he only knows his games but luckily
there was a drive-through Starbucks
there Ryan and I got a [ __ ] one of
those breakfast sandwiches and I was
hungry then so I know what it's like to
be hungry that certainly is a plight
yeah do you think honestly and I mean
you're in love with this man and you see
him a lot do you think he could survive
outdoors like and let me pick an element
and you tell me how long did it survive
in it all right
okay rain Oh cold or a tropical oh good
question just so you know let's go
because those are two varies well look
I'll support Tom Cruise over here and
let's go with uh let's go ahead warm
warm hell no I think that's so reason
being is that he's really susceptible to
mosquitoes and I know what it's like to
live in the tropics and with anywhere
there's a rain puddle is where
mosquitoes lay their lays lay their eggs
and you would be just yeah you're a big
butt in the cold
this guy ghosts you with Edmonton in
flip-flops
I think he's he has like height or some
type of like walrus but he does not feel
any cool I could stick my foot in a
puddle of icy water and won't feel a
thing
you know it's not the sugar foot I'm a
survivor in : dude dude no here's what
I'm saying is warm rain so warm rain no
because of the mosquitoes
yeah I know he cries about like a single
mosquito but that's your you're acting
so rudely that I can't even explain
myself and it's not the truth you have
no idea what my elements are do you
think what I do survive are do you think
they bite you can survive in the cold
like I couldn't yeah I'm a baby in the
cool I would die how long are you saying
dude because when I was in Thailand I
was out in the [ __ ] jungles no you
were not you fella knew up up like a
plant terrarium outside of the [ __ ]
hotel yeah no I I've been out in the
forest and stuff that's true no I don't
know okay yeah okay
[Music]